It's over.
I think it's just getting started.
We killed someone.
It was self-defense.
Ever since Jake ran off
to Mexico,
Murder Club have been looking
extremely guilty.
So, we all got the same
message?
Simon says, "Do what I say,
or everyone will know
what you did."
We have to figure out who
Simon Says is.
And until then, we need to do
whatever they say.
They're blackmailing us.
Oh my God.
Ahhh!
What the hell are you
two doing?
Whoever Simon Says is,
they're getting more twisted.
You're actually going
through with this.
What does this psycho want?
Whoa.
Go Jake!
We have to put an end to this.
Ahh!
You are making a big mistake.
There have been so many lies.
Did you tell anybody?
And rumors,
about Jake since he
disappeared.
Simon Says come out!
Ahhh!
I think it's time
for the truth.
Ahhh!